let's begin with the mantra
making it to the super bowl was an
accomplishment i definitely liked
winning the super bowl more than
losing all in favor kicking pat out of
the group second order of business
project xo our coaches can't scout a
real qb to replace us
if they're too busy scouting a fake qb i
really don't think we're gonna be
replaced
i'm gonna try my best finally
another kirk cousins fine it's time for
fake qb prospect
brock moxie
we're going to need to think young and
hip so i enlisted drew lock into his
ears
is my mana station slash
state-of-the-art draft sim really
banking on you all to stage your voice
job step one get the word out
you know i'm hearing a lot of good
things about this brock moxie
i don't trust justin field's background
you know ohio state
you know brock moxie with the north
hawaii christian military that place is
a thank you beatback
wow step two hide videos
well there's almost no tape on trey
lance so you know i love them
yeah uh you know who there's even less
tape on
bro you look great but we're not
supposed to see your face step three
let the media do its thing connor brock
moxie
is the hype real look lefko my player
comp is patrick mahomes mixed with the
trickster god loki my sources are saying
that every other qb besides brock moxie
is a low class idiot who hates football
so keeping our jobs whoops creating
brock moxie
what's happening oh that's right madden
now lets you physically create a
character
hello i'm rookie brock moxie and i don't
even have a
baby voice oh kill kill kill
but things work out for me i'm high
hurry he runs a 4 240.
god he escaped the pocket
yeah man i just think who would i want
to work in a coal mine with and i
dropped that guy man
prepare to have a sophomore smug in hell
watch out offensive lineman out of four
remember this drop season focus on your
own line
[Music]
huh what's this must start
quarterback controversy gee god please
think of all the children with their
andy dalton bears jerseys